you know the main thing that i've been
seeing recently is i feel like my
content and especially even more so
content of
uh women who are larger than me of
plus-sized women of women of color is
their content gets censored
hey everyone i'm abby sharpe welcome to
my new series fed up
every episode i will be sitting down
with a fellow influencer or content
creator to ask some tough questions and
have real uncensored unscripted
discussions without the shame and
judgment because we're all just a little
fed up right i fed up with this world
so today i'm very excited because we're
going to be chatting with one of my
favorite lifestyle creators and new mom
sierra schultzy now before we dive in i
want to remind you all to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
both for dieting discussion and also
infertility and pregnancy loss
discussion
i also want to remind you all to
subscribe this channel and ring that
little bell so that you never miss out
on an episode
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor commenter
there is a reason why i don't critique
people's coffee orders here on abby's
kitchen
coffee to me
is sacred it's like religion like
you mess with that
you're asking for trouble so naturally
i'm always down to try new coffee and i
have to say this commenter coffee
is a total game changer the way it works
is that cometier partners with the best
regional specialty coffee roasters then
grinds and brews the coffee to
perfection before flash freezing it to
lock in freshness and flavor
then instead of waiting for anything to
brew you just add a capsule to eight
ounces of hot water cold water or milk
and watch it melt together honestly this
has already given me back hours of my
life that i otherwise would have been
waiting for fresh coffee to brew or for
the local barista to call out my name so
for hot coffee you just add a frozen
capsule straight from the freezer to a
cup and add eight ounces of hot water on
top to melt and stir
and for a cold iced latte you just
combine six ounces of milk and ice and
then pour the melted capsule on top and
mix it up
it's super smooth and balanced and
delicious and a great time saving
addition to my morning routine so if you
want to try commentary out yourself
they've got a special offer for fans of
the channel so right now you can get 20
off of your first purchase using my
purchase link below that's 10 free
capsules of coffee and always free
shipping
so thank you so much for joining me
sierra i'm really excited to chat yeah
thank you so much for having me i'm
really excited i'm a huge fan of your
channel so it's an honor to be here
first of all for folks who maybe aren't
already followers they definitely should
be but can you quickly explain you know
a bit about who you are and what you
cover on your channels
yeah so i make fashion and lifestyle
videos on my main channel and i kind of
very publicly
discovered the body positive community
and went on this confidence journey
throughout the lifespan of my channel so
that's become like a really integral
part of what i do there and then also i
have a vlog channel with my husband it's
called sierra and steven irl and there
we just kind of started documenting our
life you know that was kind of the thing
to do like five years ago would start a
second channel
um and so we did that and
um it's really been a wonderful space
for us to document our journey trying to
conceive and then going through my
pregnancy and then now having my
daughter grace
yeah i mean i like you i'm a huge fan
and i love both of your channels there's
always something new to learn and also
just fun to watch you guys interact i
love it um
but i want to chat about you know diet
culture because obviously you mentioned
body positivity and diet culture is all
around us but it seems to me that you're
really able to see through a lot of that
and really like stay focused on what
works for you so i'm wondering if you
could tell us a little bit more about
your history with food and dieting and
how you got to where you are today yeah
i mean i thank you for saying that i
appreciate that it's definitely not been
the case for most of my life and that's
been
um a new thing i would say over the past
five years for me of just learning to
cut through all the noise and be like
okay what what can i do to live my life
in a way that makes me feel good in a
way that makes me feel healthy and a way
that just makes me the best version of
myself and
you know i grew up in the 2000s and so
it was very much that attitude of diet
culture and
the what i always talk about for me it
was very much this pursuit of thinness
and i
for a long time i disguised it as well i
just i just want to be healthy or you
know oh well i just want to feel good
about myself and actually what ended up
happening is right before i went to
college i lost a bunch of weight
um in not the most healthy way and i
expected that to fix everything i was
like okay i'm here i'm going to college
and i have you know the the body that i
always wanted right and all my
insecurities should go away but what
ended up happening was i had never felt
more insecure i was hyper fixating on
everything and the reality is
it was probably one of the most
unhealthy parts of my life although i
was much thinner i
was restricting i was constantly
chasing different diets and my body was
not in
a good place and so
from there is when i shortly after that
i started youtube and i discovered this
body positive community and i realized
like oh wait i don't i don't have to
like feel
horrible about myself all the time i
don't have to
constantly be obsessing over every inch
of my body and it's been very freeing
for me to discover that and it's
definitely a journey that i'm still on
but i look back at that that 19 year old
me who
was just
really struggling and i'm like wow i
have i really have come so far
yeah i mean i think so many of us you
know it doesn't really matter
what your body looks like to begin with
it's like so many of us can identify
with that you know 19 year old self and
that idea that oh if i you know as soon
as i lose this weight as soon as i get a
toned stomach as soon as i change this
part of my face or whatever that i'm
going to feel better about myself my
life is going to get better and that's
just not really how it works right we
really have to do the work
on the inside and i i love that you've
shared that with us and that you know we
get to see
that vibrant self come forward in your
channel and through your content because
it's just so obvious thank you so much
that's so kind okay so
moving on to motherhood because i know
you recently become a mom like you
mentioned to little grace who's how old
is grace now uh she's three and a half
months ah
you're you're almost
through the weeds that's that's just
hold on a little a little longer um but
you know i know you've got pcos and
you've talked about your journey as
you're trying to get pregnant um i'm
curious how did you feel when you got
that diagnosis
you know it was kind of a double-edged
sword because on one hand right it's
it's this realization that
trying to get pregnant is probably gonna
be a lot more complicated um but on the
other hand it's kind of like when i got
my mental health diagnosis it was almost
a relief of like
oh okay so
here's what's wrong and now i can make a
plan to fix it um because when i didn't
know what was going on with my body and
why i was having these super irregular
periods and why
we were struggling to get pregnant
i i didn't know what to do to fix that
because i didn't know what was wrong
and once we figured out what was wrong i
was able to work with my medical team
and get a pcos dietitian
and really try to like treat what was
going on with my body and then i was
able to get pregnant and so
it is kind of a complicated thing i
think any sort of medical diagnosis
there's the one side where it's like man
this sucks like why can't why why is
this happening why do i have this thing
and then on the other hand it's like
okay well at least now we have the
answer and now we can work
to try and make this better yeah i
totally agree it's kind of it's you know
you feel like it's you got the good and
the bad i know for me when i was
diagnosed with pcos though
admittedly i think that since then a few
doctors have actually questioned this
diagnosis but still
i know for me
i felt very scared right like i actually
didn't know that much about pcos at the
time and i remember my re telling me and
like i feeling like
it was like a death sentence and of
course that sounds so dramatic now but
and obviously not true um but i just
feel like hormones are so tricky because
there's no cure right it's just
management and there are so many
unknowns and things that i couldn't
control um and because something with
like pcos and there is no actual cure
for it um they're just it just felt like
a very scary diagnosis it's not saying
that i could just take a pill and it
would be gone so
yeah i i definitely feel you on that
yeah i think that especially with pcos
that is one of the hard things right
it's it's not like okay here's what's
happened and there's a straight solution
to this there's so many different things
to try and it can kind of it i really do
feel at least for me because i have
bipolar disorder it was kind of a
similar thing when i got diagnosed with
bipolar disorders there isn't one answer
there isn't one cure it's okay let's try
these different things and find
something that works for you
and for me with pcos a huge part of one
of the things that we tried that worked
super well for me was just changing up
my diet yeah so like let's talk about
that for a second because i know you
mentioned that you got to work with a
dietician who specialist at pcos which i
was so happy to hear um so what do you
think was like the if you could just
pick one thing that is being really
helpful for you in helping you manage
your pcos from a dietary perspective
what would that be
yeah i never i never want to give
medical advice because i am not the
dietitian but just what worked for me
the biggest thing for me was just upping
my protein i am a vegetarian and that is
not typically the best like most
conducive diet for pcos
and so my dietitian she was so wonderful
she really helped she was like okay you
want to stay vegetarian but we need to
manage your pcos so here's what we need
to try
and once i was able to up my protein
that just made a huge difference
oh i totally agree i think that so many
people i get texts and dms every single
day messages from so many people who are
struggling with pcos and of course if
you google like pcos diet you're going
to get so much pseudoscience so many
restrictive recommendations cut out
gluten cut out dairy cut out all these
other foods and the reality is is that i
don't like to think about that we
actually have evidence that dieting can
actually make pcos worse so i like to
think about like you like how do we add
more things into our diet how do we add
some protein to dress up naked carbs as
we like to say um and that alone just
just focusing on adding that little bit
of protein in there to make those what i
call hunger crushing combos that alone
is going to make a huge difference for
blood sugar management and pcos
management so yeah i'm really happy to
hear that you were able to connect with
a dietitian who was able to help you
make some of those changes in also like
a non-diet way that's one of the things
that i recommend the most is if so if
you have access to a dietitian
i mean i can't recommend it enough
because like you said there is so much
pseudoscience on the internet and if i
had just googled pcos diet it probably
would have ended up doing more damage to
my body than actual help but working
with a dietitian who actually
specializes in that
i was able to first of all get
legitimate advice and second of all i
really trusted her as a source
and that was huge for me she was also
very helpful for me in making
sustainable changes to my diet it wasn't
like the first appointment a complete
overhaul of everything that i'm eating
she had me kind of walk through the
normal day of of what i eat and then say
okay how can we tweak these things to
make it more pcos friendly
um and i think that to me
was so important because coming from a
background where diet was like a scary
word right of
okay diet means restriction
diet means controlling every single
thing that um i put into my body diet
means calorie counting
um working with a dietician was a little
bit scary at first but it ended up being
a really wonderful thing because
it it wasn't that at all it wasn't about
restriction it wasn't about counting
calories it was about treating what was
going on in my body with food to make my
body work better and it was a wonderful
experience
ah i'm that's music to my ears and i'm
so happy to hear that um and i always
tell people like it is a red flag if you
are working with a practitioner whether
that's a nutritionist or naturopath or a
dietitian or doctor whoever and without
giving you any legitimate reason without
asking you what do you normally eat what
do you like to eat what are your normal
dietary patterns if they're just
automatically being like oh yeah cut out
dairy cut out gluten it's like
why
like you don't if they don't give you a
legitimate reason that is tailored to
you and your needs that's a huge red
flag for me that alone would be reason
for me to like seek out a different
practitioner yeah and one one of the
things that my dietician did is we did
extensive testing of like blood tests of
hormone levels of all this kind of stuff
i did like a month-long um like hormone
cycle test to see what my levels were at
different points during my cycle
and then we made our plan for my diet
changes based on that and so it really
felt like okay let's figure out what's
going on with my body not just what is
the one-size-fits-all change for pcos
and
um
a couple months after that is when i
first got pregnant and unfortunately i
did miscarry that first pregnancy but it
was a
a big realization that okay my body can
get pregnant and my cycle is becoming
more regular through these dietary
changes
yeah all little baby steps so i'm so
happy to hear that it worked out now you
just mentioned of course a miscarriage
and i know that you've had some bumps to
baby um and i'm a fellow infertility
warrior myself and i've had a few
pregnancy losses as well
but i know that i have immense thin
privilege and you know it was never my
weight or my body that was being blamed
for my circumstance but i'm curious what
was your experience with the medical
community when you found out that you
had pcos and you were having trouble
conceiving you know i i actually was
really fortunate in that i had a really
good experience with my medical team and
i never once felt like shamed or
blamed for my size and i know that is
kind of an outlier for plus-sized women
and i also still have a lot of privilege
in the body that i'm in and so i know
that the experiences of so many other
people can be so much worse
but you know it was a really wonderful
experience for me and that i felt like
my medical team truly cared about why
this was happening and how we could fix
it and didn't just immediately jump to
it's your weight
yeah i'm so happy to hear that because i
know statistically we know that you know
fat phobia in the medical community does
play such a huge role in contributing to
disparities in health
and like infertility is just so
frustrating and unfair enough um and
also it does not discriminate so it's
really too bad that a lot of people are
facing those kinds of um kind of
struggles with the healthcare community
but i'm really so happy to hear that
that was not the case
i mean especially with my dietitian
i actually
i seeked out a dietitian who
specifically said that she um did haze
and was body positive
and one of the things that really kind
of took me aback in a positive way was
in our first meeting when we were
talking about the different changes we
could make to my diet she said now with
you know getting your diet changed and
having it more conducive to pcos that
could possibly result in you losing
weight are you okay with that
and that was a huge like talk about red
flags that was a huge green flag for me
where i was like
the i think almost all the time in
medical environments weight loss is
viewed as 100 a positive thing and
sometimes it can be often times it can
be but also i think
her bringing that to me from like an
emotional standpoint and just saying you
know hey this might happen you might
lose weight are you okay with that
instead of and good news this might make
you lose weight i
thought that was really wonderful and
it really changed the way that i look at
diet and that that word diet doesn't
have to be a dirty word it can be
something that's really positive for
your life
absolutely i love that i mean like if
you think of it as a continuum it's like
most of the time you're being told you
know forget about the the health
benefits if you maybe you know being
able to get your recycle back and and
conceiving like this could cause weight
loss like let's try to lose weight to
like weight loss as a as a happy side
effect to
you know just so you know like it could
you could lose weight but uh that that's
absolutely not the purpose here so i
love that way of looking at it and i
agree that's such a positive spin on
this especially in the circumstance that
you know you're in and the fact that of
course like when we're dealing with pcos
we're really trying to you know heal our
cycle and improve our our kind of
reproductive health so i think that
should be top of mind that should be the
focus and what happens to our weight is
just a potential side effect right and
and at the point that i am in my life
right now i don't care if my body
changes if i lose weight if i gain
weight i'm really happy with who i am
and the way my body feels right now but
there were times in my life where my
body changing whether it was gaining
weight or losing weight could have been
really triggering for me and really
difficult for me and so i just
appreciated her asking that because you
never know the headspace that someone is
in
oh 100 and you i mean as a dietitian i
would never want to trigger um you know
disordered eating or kind of pull
somebody back into that headspace so i i
think that's that was a great fit and
i'm glad you found her whoever this
dietician is
she's a saint she's on team abbey i love
it so obviously you found a unicorn in
your medical community um and i'm
curious like do you have any advice for
folks out there in larger bodies about
you know trying to find a practitioner
who like you said like doesn't just tell
them to go away with this diet and come
back when you lost 20 pounds or like are
pressuring them to kind of restrict or
diet at such a critical time like
pregnancy
yeah i think honestly asking those
questions in the first appointment or if
you can get in contact with them before
the appointment
that's even better um i think
it's so important to find medical
providers who not only you trust but who
you feel really comfortable with and and
with bringing up what's going on in your
body and
um like i said i was super lucky to find
that my ob throughout my pregnancy was
also wonderful and
you know the only time weight was
brought up during my pregnancy was when
i brought it up and so i i really
appreciated that i i kind of went
through my pregnancy kind of feeling
like i was waiting right for
um something to be said or a little
comment here and there or even something
bigger being brought up but um i had
told my ob at the beginning of my
pregnancy i was like hey you know if my
weight at any time is becoming a health
concern for me or the baby please let me
know i'm i'm happy to to talk about that
and
she never she said okay yeah i'll let
you know things look great right now she
never brought it up again and
at one point about i think halfway
through my pregnancy i asked you know
hey this is
you know looking at my paperwork this is
how much weight i've gained is that
where i should be
do you have any recommendations and she
was just like no looks great like you're
you're in a great spot we're happy with
the way everything looks and so let's
just proceed as normal and
you know i i'm so grateful because i
know like i said that's that's kind of
an outlier experience for plus size
women but you know i really lucked out
yeah i am so happy to hear that i think
i mean i don't know if this is the
experience that you had
as like a cobit pregnancy because i also
had a covered pregnancy my son is um
older than grace 13 months so i was like
first first uh first wave pregnancy
and um but basically i one of the perks
for me as a covet mom was that um there
were just fewer appointments fewer
opportunities for people to make
offensive comments about my body that
was changing um you know i i will never
forget that you know going into the obs
office at the beginning of my pregnancy
the nurse of course weighed weighs me
and made some comments like
oh it's okay if you you know if you if
you gain two pounds this week um you
know next week you'll probably maybe you
won't gain as much or something like
that and i thought
like
am i some kind of robot where i'm
supposed to gain a perfect one pound
every single week like that's not how
this is going to happen
um and then interestingly i switched to
a midwife uh later on in my pregnancy
and she didn't weigh me at all
no she never made a comment about my
weight big or small honestly
i think it's offensive to comment on
um pregnant people's bodies no matter
what big or small you never know how
they're feeling so if you say to
somebody oh you're so tiny like you
never know if that's also going to be
triggering to someone who in their mind
is thinking
am i doing something wrong am i is my
baby in danger like is it am i am i just
you know are they malnourished are they
going to be failing to thrive etc and
the same of course goes to telling a
woman oh my gosh you look so big which
of course you i heard a million times as
well in my pregnancy so for those who
are watching right now if you've got a
pregnant person in your life just don't
say anything just tell them they look
glowing you don't you don't have to say
anything about size or shape yeah i
think it's one of those things where
it's the little comments that don't seem
like a big deal but they really chip
away at you
over time and you know for me like i
said my ob gyn was really wonderful
throughout my pregnancy didn't make
those comments but when i was in the
hospital um one of the postpartum nurses
this is maybe two or three days after
birth said something along the lines of
like
uh and don't weigh yourself when you get
home because you still will have like a
couple pounds of bloat and um you don't
want to be discouraged and i remember
stephen and i both kind of being like
but why would i be discouraged like why
would i be discouraged about the way
that i am or the size that i am like i
totally understand of course i'm you
know there's going to be more bloat
weight but it's it's not going to
it's not going to change the way my body
is my body is whether i weigh myself or
not
um it it just it's i think a lot of
those little comments that really don't
seem like a big deal on the surface but
they are always rooted in that pursuit
of thinness
um and for me i there was a time in my
life where i absolutely was triggered by
numbers and weight i'm kind of past that
now and so at my prenatal appointments i
was you know comfortable just standing
on the scale seeing the number it
doesn't bother me
but um i have some friends who have gone
through pregnancy who are still you know
affected by those numbers and one of the
things that they said was incredibly
helpful was just telling the doctors hey
you know i have a history of disordered
eating or i have a history of you know
whatever it is and saying can i can i
stand on the scale backwards um and that
that was incredibly helpful for them so
if you're someone who's you know still
kind of in
in the pits of getting through body
image and disordered eating and numbers
are triggering for you i highly
recommend you know trying those kind of
things because
if seeing those numbers is harmful to
you
you don't have to see them
yeah i mean we call it a blind weight we
would never want that weight to then
trigger in mom's head oh my gosh i
gained three pounds this week or
whatever i should be eating less
now is not the time to be dieting folks
and your body is going to do what it
needs to do to grow that life
and so yeah i i mean i think for sure um
engaging in a blind weight is a really
great way to to go so interesting what
that nurse said to you because i that
triggered to me a memory of before i had
children myself
that
of course hollywood paints this picture
of you have the baby and then
flat flat stomach again
that is not what happens folks your
uterus is still quite enlarged after
having housed a child that is like you
know eight to ten pounds and a lot of
water weight
and so you know you still look a good
six months pregnant for a little while
um after you deliver that baby and so
yeah it is it was definitely a shock to
me with my first pregnancy that like why
why do i still look pregnant the baby's
gone
um but that's just totally normal of
course to be expected and also just like
unfortunate that that nurse expected
that your number one priority was going
to be that your weight would drop when
you have to
recover you know feed yourself feed a
baby learn how to breastfeed you know
like sleep maybe um all of those way
more important things than figuring out
you know how much weight you've lost
yeah you know i had had an emergency
c-section and so i'm trying to figure
out healing from that you know it's a
kind of traumatic experience at first
and bonding with my baby and
breastfeeding the last thing on my mind
was oh i can't wait to get home and
weigh myself and see
you know how much weight i've lost but i
better wait because i don't want to be
discouraged
yeah
bizarre what a
yeah
there's pressure that's put on women
from the first day out of the hospital
of all right babies out gotta
bounce back
the thing is back to what my whole life
is different my body's different not
only have i gone through nine months of
changes but i'm now a mom and i have a
baby to take care of and my routine and
my life and what i eat and what i do is
probably gonna change and
i
if the the phrases bounce back
i don't wanna bounce back to who i was
before i had grace because
my life has forever changed because of
it
yeah i always say the same thing i mean
you know i don't want my 19 year old
body in life anymore because my 33 year
old body life for me
is so much more full and i'm not saying
that you know life without children is
not full but for me of course like this
was what i wanted this is what i worked
my ass off for like as an ivf mom like i
really had to want it this time
so
like i i never want to go back to that
and i'm forever grateful for this body
that housed and fed uh two lives like it
is such an amazing thing and it's such a
transformation so
i really feel like we've got to get rid
of that whole bounce back mentality
because
a it's not particularly helpful for for
new moms um but also like why would we
want that this is that's not what we
signed up for
yeah
no it it's so interesting um because i
do think that
there has been so much progress in the
way that we talk about women's bodies
and the way
that we have kind of been fighting back
against diet culture but i think that
that hasn't really extended yet to the
postpartum body and i really hope it
does soon because i
i see so many comments and messages from
my viewers who you know are going
through the same things that i am and
are going you know how are you
handling this whole idea of bounce back
and how are you doing it because i feel
like i'm drowning
and i just my heart goes out to everyone
who who's feeling that way and doesn't
have the support to
you know really feel like they can
settle into their new mom body because
it it's a difficult thing to do even you
know i feel like i'm at probably the the
peak of my confidence in my life and
it's still hard where i am now i can't
imagine going through this when
i was still when i hadn't gone on this
body confidence journey yet i can't
imagine how difficult it would be
to try and accept my postpartum body
yeah i i totally agree and i'm this is
why you know for so many reasons i think
we're all so
um grateful that we have content
creators like you out there to to help
us through some of these um you know
challenging challenging questions and
and challenging times where um otherwise
the the internet and the wellness
community is just so
rife with toxic diet culture and um
unrealistic body expectations especially
for new moms
the whole fitspo world as it relates to
motherhood is
it's a lot to take in and so i
understand why so many people feel the
need to you know
uh sneak in that workout and like the
every single moment that the baby's down
it's like you know there are other
things in our life other than just kind
of getting ourselves back to that
pre-baby body state
um
yeah so um and you know you mentioned a
support system tell me about you know i
know steven's just so fantastic we love
watching him we love seeing you guys
interact he's just such a gem like you
guys are such a um like a like a bright
ball of energy and light together thank
you just so beautiful to watch your
relationship grow um especially now as a
dad i mean like i cried through your
birth story because i was like he's
gonna be such a great dad
um but i'm curious like is there
anything that he was able to help you
with
um you know both in this postpartum uh
journey and also in you know the
infertility journey and pregnancy and
things like that was what was the the
most important uh gift that he gave you
as a support system and team member
oh that's such like a complex question
because i feel like i could just gush
about him in 100 different things that
he does
but i think postpartum honestly the
biggest thing has been he's given me the
gift of sleep once i was able to
pump and we introduced a bottle um he
takes he always takes either the late
night feed or the morning feed and i
take the other one and um i cannot
stress enough how
amazing that has been for not only like
my physical health and well-being but
also my mental health and well-being
um because
sleep the sleep deprivation is real and
so
um having him help with that and i think
what's been really wonderful is
never once has he acted like he's doing
me a favor by doing that it's always
been you know this is just as much his
job as it is mine
and when i was breastfeeding and he
wasn't able to you know take one of the
feeds from me he woke up with me for
every feed and he sat there with me and
talked with me and we watched tv and we
laughed and i didn't feel like i'm alone
in this and i'm up all night and i you
know i'm just
just stuck i always felt like i had my
partner with me to help me through this
and
um that's been really really wonderful
oh i love to hear that and and i totally
agree i i of course sleep is so
important and you know getting those
little moments for you whether it's like
to take a shower like these are basic
things like of course we deserve these
things um and feed yourself and all of
those things that we obviously need to
make time for but i i agree with what
you're saying and that like none of
those things are actually helpful if
they come with a side of like guilt and
like a guilt trip because like as a as
moms we get enough of that right we are
bombarded with we're like this this kind
of narrative of us not doing enough not
being fit enough not um you know feeding
our baby enough or or like not having
unmedicated births or not breastfeeding
long enough or whatever like there's
so much pressure on us from every angle
every direction the last thing we need
is to hear from our partner that we're
not momming enough we're not you know
doing enough in that in that regard as
well and you're a working mom too like
you are an entrepreneur so i mean i i i
feel you on that there's just so much to
do
um so i think that having a partner who
is not only going to give you that time
give you those resources but also not
make it seem like they're doing you a
favor is
it's
yeah what he always says he's like i
don't understand why
because there is very much this attitude
of when
uh a woman is doing all the child care
it's like oh well of course she's the
mom but when uh uh the dad does it's
like father of the year oh my goodness
you are the the greatest thing that's
ever happened to this planet and i
remember stephen and i talking about
that and he's like
why why do people praise dads for doing
like the bare minimum like that's kind
of sad like why why is it expected that
women will do
everything and men who do anything are
you know given a gold medal
um and i remember i was saying i sat
down with him and i was like stephen do
you you do realize you're the outlier
right like
it's amazing what you're doing but this
is not like the typical thing that
people expect
of a father and
um i'm super grateful for it but
you know a lot of people this just isn't
the reality for a lot of people and i
remember we kind of had this this whole
conversation about the expectations of a
parental role from a mom versus a dad is
it's different and it's sad i don't
think it should be different
yeah unfortunately it's not and of
course everyone's got to find uh you
know a a family orientation and like
like a division of responsibilities
within their household that works for
them and doesn't make them feel
resentful or you know over over um
stretched and things like that but yeah
it is unfortunate that society like our
society has such different expectations
for mothers versus
fathers and like you said it's like a
mom's just doing our job a a dad is
babysitting their own child
no that's not how they're kidding one of
the things that stephen and i have
really tried to do which i think has
been really helpful for both of us and
not trying to do that one-upping right
or that like guilting is um advocating
for ourselves and asking for breaks when
we need it um and really trying to honor
what the other person needs even when
it's not super convenient so
you know if steven's super exhausted
he'll be like hey i really need you to
take the morning feed i have to sleep
and i'm like cool i got it no problem
and
i think
it's it's easy to get in the mindset of
well now
he owes me right or i do something and
it's now i owe him um or now he owes me
and what it is really is not trying to
keep track of those things but just
saying i will always be here to help
when you need it and i know you'll
always be there when i need it and
feeling empowered to ask for an hour to
sit by myself him doing the same feeling
empowered to say hey i just want to go
play video games for an hour i'm like
yes absolutely go go do that and
i think it's so easy to get caught up in
the tallying of those things but i think
once you let go of that and you're just
like you know what
we are here for each other and we are
going to give each other the breaks that
they need
um it's freeing and i think it's it's
not only good for our health as a couple
but i think it's better for like our
whole family it's better for grace as
well
oh yeah there's nothing that'll like
ruin a marriage faster than what i call
like score keeping like the scoreboard
that you were talking about
um but i want to get back to fertility
for a moment because i know you know we
talked about um having a miscarriage
before grace and obviously i'm so sorry
for your loss but so happy that you got
your little rainbow um was there
anything that you did to help you heal
and move on with confidence when you
were able to conceive again or did you
find like i know you mentioned your that
you kind of were just kind of waiting
for something bad to happen how did you
how did you get through that in your
pregnancy you know the the first 12
weeks
were
really difficult and i do feel like once
i hit week 12 maybe week 11 a switch
flipped and i was like okay
um i i think i'm i'm in the clear i
think things are gonna be okay
um but it really was gradual you know i
had had two miscarriages the first one
was at eight weeks and the second one
was at four weeks i think it was little
little things that made me feel better
over time it was okay we passed the
point
of my second miscarriage now we passed
the point of my first miscarriage now i
heard the heartbeat now we had each of
those little things that i think built
up my confidence
um but one thing that really really
helped me and i don't know if this is
going to be helpful for everyone because
not everyone is like as you know
as crazy about statistics as i am
but i
looked up a
uh chart of
this the statistic of miscarriage from
day of pregnancy so not even by week it
was literally by like you know three
weeks two days three weeks three days
and in those early days this
the percentage goes down pretty
drastically day by day and so i just
told myself if i wake up tomorrow still
pregnant my chances are getting better
and better
and so every day i would wake up and i
had the things screenshotted in my phone
and i would look at it and i'd say okay
today there's a 73 chance that this
pregnancy is going to go to term now
there's a 78 chance and going through
all of those things
um
it was really helpful for me and that i
felt like things were getting better and
that if i could just make it through one
more hour one more day my odds were
gonna get better
and by the time i reached 11 weeks and
those odds were great i was like okay
you know i think
i think i can delete this chart off my
phone i think that helped me through
this difficult time and i think now i'm
ready to
celebrate being pregnant um but it is
really difficult and i i feel like i can
say this because i had a difficult birth
i think the first trimester was more
difficult than childbirth
um you know childbirth is incredibly
difficult i was in labor for 60 hours i
had an emergency c-section but at the
end of it i got my baby when you're four
weeks pregnant and you're starting to
get nauseous and you're so scared of
losing this thing that you feel like you
don't even have yet
nine months feel so far off
and you don't get that
that
instant
kind of reminder of like but i'm gonna
have my baby in a day or in a couple
hours when you're in labor
it's like will
will i have a baby in nine months i
don't know am i going is it worth it to
go through all of this
and so to anyone who's watching this in
their first trimester who's like in just
in the thick of that like
it is not going to be like that for your
whole pregnancy at least for me it
wasn't i hope it's not for you
um but it things will get so much better
yeah i totally agree first trimester is
the pits especially when you're dealing
with that kind of and you've had losses
before and you're you know that is also
on your mind and making things even
worse and the nausea like the whole
combo it's not fun and then at the same
time like trying to keep it a secret
like not telling people and that's one
thing for me where i do think you know
it's kind of just a societal thing of oh
we don't announce until the second
trimester
after my first two miscarriages with my
pregnancy with grace i said to steven i
was like you know what i need to tell
our families and i need to tell my close
friends and he was like i'm 100 agree
and so we told them in not like a super
you know oh my gosh i'm pregnant you
know surprise reveal it was like hey
guys i'm pregnant and i need support
right now um because i'm only three and
a half weeks
and that was so wonderful for me and i
think
telling you don't have to announce it to
the world but i think telling your
support system
can be incredibly helpful in getting
through those first few weeks
i 100 agree and i obviously it's a
personal choice whether like you feel
more comfortable waiting because i i've
been in the thick of the infertility
community for so long that some people
feel so anxious that they need to hold
on to that
even longer than sometimes in the first
trimester because they're just so uns
uncertain um but for me i was the same
way i i needed to tell my story i needed
to everybody to know that i'm pregnant
and i'm you know i need your prayers and
i need you to think about me
um and and this baby to to see us
through because i knew that if things
did head south i
then i would really need their support
then i would really need to talk to
somebody um and i didn't then want to
have to kind of disclose oh the reason
i'm sad and i can't come out is because
i just had a miscarriage it's like they
were already in it with me um so yeah
again totally a personal i um personal
situation personal choice but i agree
with you that that was also something
that was helpful for me to kind of get
through that first um uncertain uh stage
of pregnancy yeah uh yeah it's it's
totally a personal thing and i know that
there are i'm sure plenty of people who
would say you know they actually prefer
to just it's easier when it's just
keeping it to themselves
but something i didn't even think about
until i told my mom about the pregnancy
was that they were grieving too you know
they were grieving the pregnancy loss as
well they were grieving the loss of what
they thought was going to be their first
grandchild and so
you know being able to go through the
early stages of my pregnancy with grace
with them i think was healing for all of
us
yeah i felt the exact same thing i was i
was i was so relieved to tell my family
um when we had a successful transfer
after so many losses um and you know i
also kind of felt like a need like i
want to protect them from that pain that
i was feeling like my parents and things
like that um but once i kind of opened
the floodgates and and let everybody in
i was just so grateful for that love and
support so it was a good choice for me
now i know that the internet can be a
really hard place and we both work you
know work in this youtube and content
creator space and you know particularly
for people in larger bodies it can be
very cruel and there's tons of trolls
and you've been so open about your
struggles here in your community i'm
curious did you get a lot of like fat
phobic trolling um and if so
how do you not internalize that hate
you know it's interesting because my
core audience is you know they're people
who believe the same things that i
believe and people who are on the same
confidence journey that i am and so my
core audience the people who watch you
know all my videos and my vlogs and
everything they're the best they're
chill they're you know they're not
making those comments but it's when i
would have videos go viral outside my
audience that it would invite in this
community or this group of people
outside my community who did make those
comments and at first
it's like
it's really painful you know the first
couple videos i had that go viral and
just seeing all of these comments of
people just really picking me apart it
it made me go wow maybe i'm not like as
far along on my confidence journey as i
thought because this still
really hurts
um and then a couple months go by you
know i kind of don't really have as many
videos that are going outside my
audience and then another one happens
and then i started to feel more sad for
those people um because if they're
holding me to this ridiculous standard
imagine the standard they're holding
themselves to and if they're sitting
there picking me apart imagine what they
do when they look in the mirror at
themselves and it made me sad i was like
you know what i
i'm sad for them and i'm i'm happy that
i'm not in that place anymore and i
think that that shift is really when i
stopped caring as much and
it also was a purposeful shift maybe
about maybe about two years ago i think
about around january of last year
where i said maybe i don't want to be
making videos where i'm trying to get a
ton of views anymore maybe i don't want
to go viral maybe i don't
need you know
a million views on a video maybe by like
200 000 is great um where all those
people are actually getting something of
value from the content and who are part
of my community
and i kind of purposely stopped
chasing views
and not only was that great for my
community and you know not having to
deal with all the things that come with
a video going viral but i think it was
also just good for my mental health as a
creator where i stopped caring if my
videos were getting a lot of views
because i knew that the
the value that the smaller viewership
was getting from my videos was
higher
yeah i think that's really great advice
for you know for content creators and
like myself like i i know that this this
world is is tough it's it's odd times
ruthless people are mean and i'm
actually hearing from a lot of content
creators right now that
we're all really in agreement that the
burnout is real and and if we're not
creating content that serves us and that
feels good to us and that is going to um
you know support our mental health then
it's just it's just not worth doing it's
this is not worth killing ourselves over
and not sleeping and you know none of
that this is youtube like we have to
still enjoy what we're doing or else
we're not going to want to do it anymore
so i'm i'm really happy to hear that you
found a kind of a content creation
calendar and and approach that's working
well for you yeah i think what hap when
it really happened that now that i'm
thinking about it is when i hit a
million subscribers because that was
like always my goal with my channel
right is oh i'm someday i wanna i wanna
hit a million subscribers and that would
be so amazing to get my plaque and you
know that's like the the ultimate goal
and then i hit a million subscribers and
i was like well now what
what what was what was i chasing what
was all of this for
and
i kind of sat with it for a little while
and i was like
what is my goal now what what am i doing
this for and i realized
it's for the people who are getting
something out of my videos that's more
than just of view it's for the people
who are this is a part of their
confidence journey it's for the people
who are stumbling across this video just
because maybe they're interested in the
topic or fashion or lifestyle and then
walking away maybe thinking about their
body in a little bit of a different way
and i realized that i can make that
impact without having videos that are
going viral outside my audience
and so
i really just started to think about
okay well what kind of content do i like
making and what kind of content can i
give something of value to my audience
through and i feel like since then i
have just been so much happier with the
content i'm creating
yes i totally agree super helpful advice
um i know that you've used the term body
positive of course to describe the
content on your channel like you spoke
about
how do you feel about thin influencers
using the term body positive to describe
themselves and their experience you know
i think it goes beyond just thin
influencers but i think you know white
influencers as well i'm a white woman
and i've used the term body positive to
talk about my channel and my journey for
a really long time
but i learned over the past year or so
that the body positive community was
started by women of color plus-sized
women of color specifically and that
term has really become such an umbrella
term
that on one hand it's wonderful because
so many people are learning about this
community
and this you know mental shift that has
been so freeing but on the other hand
it's become such an umbrella term that
it's
people are forgetting where it came from
i didn't know where it came from
and the people who started this movement
aren't being credited for it and i think
it's a it's a difficult thing to
navigate because it's amazing that it
has helped so many people
but it's also
it's become such an umbrella term that
it's no longer being credited to the
people who needed this movement the most
which is the people who started it plus
size women of color
and so i've been really trying to be
cognizant about making sure that i'm
uplifting that community and i've also
started to try and change my own
language to use body confidence to
discuss my own journey
and use body positive as more of the
term to discuss the wider movement
um but it's so it is so difficult
because if
i never want to tell someone how to
label their
body or their journey um i don't think
that's my place and i think there's
enough people in the world telling women
how they should talk about their bodies
what they should do with their bodies i
don't want to be another voice in that
but also i i do think it's important
that we all recognize that
um some people carry thin privilege some
people carry white privilege and we need
to make sure that we're uplifting the
communities who need this movement the
most
yes i actually have a whole video on
this and i interviewed a few
um larger bodied uh people of color
content creators and and got their take
on it as well i've also really tried to
kind of shift language and and just be
more mindful um that you know out of
respect that this term really wasn't
designed for me so i don't want to like
purposefully profit from it or use it
out of context so you know i love body
confidence um sometimes i use body
kindness that's another really great
term um and so i think that we can just
kind of use those terms and just be more
respectful of their origins and their
history
um but i'm curious when you see
straight-sized folks on social media
like pose on certain ways to like you
know point out their role or like show a
less flattering angle
is content like that triggering or does
it feel like insensitive to you at all
you know it's complicated because on one
hand no matter what size someone is they
are going through their own confidence
struggles um and like i said when i was
at my smallest size when i entered
college i was at my most insecure and so
seeing a body that looked like mine at
that time who was embracing the
imperfections quote-unquote of their
body would have been really helpful for
me
um so i don't necessarily think that's
wrong but i do think it becomes an issue
when
that is now becoming the accepted the
digestible form of body confidence of
body positivity and then when we see
fat or plus eyes or larger body people
who are doing those same things but
they're getting the barrage of hate that
doesn't come from those straight sized
people doing that it kind of defeats the
purpose um because then the people who
are really being marginalized are
not getting the support and the message
that that original post is supposed to
do so i think it's complicated i don't
think there's a straight answer i think
it's wonderful for people of all sizes
to embrace their body but i think you
know there definitely is something to be
said that when
someone who is straight-sized is you
know showing a role that only
pops up when they contort their body a
specific way
uh is posting that versus someone who's
plus size is there's a different
response because we still consider one
to be more digestible to the larger
public
totally there's definitely a double
standard here and you know for me it's
it's also not content that i like to
make myself because i would never want
somebody to look at my body and you know
what i suggest is looking bad or
whatever and for someone else to think
wow like even at her worst
it's better than my best kind of thing
and obviously i yeah like and i we can't
control everyone's triggers and
insecurities but i know for me it just
makes me feel uncomfortable to have that
responsibility
oh if you think that's bad wait till you
see what my body looks like when i'm not
twisted and contorted that's just what
my body looks like all the time it's
definitely complicated
yeah absolutely and do you feel that
you've had to endure unique challenges
as like a plus-sized creator that a lot
of folks within privilege wouldn't you
know the main thing that i've been
seeing recently is i feel like my
content and especially even more so
content of
uh women who are larger than me of
plus-sized women of women of color is
their content gets censored a lot more
quickly than straight-sized women and
uh
it's oh it's so frustrating like i post
especially on tick tock and instagram i
posted a tick tock of me just like you
know showing my bump progression
throughout my pregnancy it got removed
for uh what was it uh
sexual activity
sexual activity i'm in a swimsuit
posing with my my
baby bump uh it's
and it's hard because you know i don't
know if that content would have gotten
removed if i was a size two
how i don't know but i know that there
definitely is a trend
where
people who have marginalized bodies
their content gets taken down much
quicker and with much less
cause yeah and that's just a perfect
example of society's
fat phobia like literally if you look at
the word fat phobia it is like a fear it
is a discomfort with the body
with a larger body with seeing more skin
um you know seeing seeing somebody like
you said size two in a crop top
you know that nobody bats an eye out
that that's the norm on instagram like
that is what we see all the time but
seeing that same crop top in a larger
body where there's just more skin to be
seen you know suddenly that's a problem
that's offensive and ultimately that
is fat phobia at its finest
so i'm really sorry that you've had to
endure that that's mind-boggling to me
but also at the same time it's like
just knowing what we know about
instagram and social media and all of
those you know societal expectations
also not surprising yeah and i mean my
my struggle with that is even just so
small so minuscule compared to what
happens to so many other plus-sized
creators like for me it's a poster to
getting taken down for other people it's
getting completely censored by the
algorithm
um and it's it's it's such a
awful thing that's going on and i think
the best thing is that more people
should talk about it um and especially
people who aren't having to deal with
that especially smaller creators
especially standard size creators who
aren't getting censored in the same way
to speak out and say hey this is wrong
and this needs we need to change these
algorithms so that this doesn't keep
happening
and you know speaking of algorithms and
social media
like i'm not sure how much you are able
to censor all the pseudoscience and diet
culture there is out there in your life
but
what are you most fed up with seeing in
this whole online wellness space oh gosh
um
if you could pick one thing you know
what i'm gonna go i'm gonna go two
things so the first thing is actually
kind of the opposite of what i feel like
i've been
kind of
kind of thinking over the past couple
years and that i'm kind of tired of
people telling women what they should
and shouldn't do with their bodies and
their diet i think a recent conversation
that came up was with lizzo and she
posted a tick tock about how she was
doing a cleanse and you know the
comments were calling her out about how
you know
there's no science behind cleanses and
this and that and i totally understand
that but also i think we need to stop
policing
women's bodies and if lizzo wants to do
her cleanse let her do her cleanse um
and i think that's something that has
been a journey for me to figure out of
for a long time i was just like anyone
who's promoting
diet culture and pseudoscience
is wrong and they need to be called out
and they need to be stopped but the
reality is
she has been steeped in the same diet
culture and the same pressure that all
of us had and if she's doing something
for her and she's enjoying it
power to her um i it's not that's not
what i'm gonna do but i think it's great
that she is doing something for her
regardless of what everyone else wants
to say and i think that's been a big
turning point for me
um but i think on the other side of that
it's so frustrating to see
the constant cycling of fad diets
um and this constant push of well have
you have you tried this diet have you
heard of this diet this is new um and
it's just learning how to cut out all
that noise and find
what actually works and what actually
makes you happy and what actually works
for your body
i think one of my one of my pet peeves
will always be people talking about
harmful chemicals because everything's a
chemical um right like there of course
are our toxins and things that are not
as good for your body but i think
i i always cringe a little bit and get a
little bit of that i don't know if i'm
gonna buy into the rest of what you're
saying when someone says oh i'm i'm on
this chemical-free
diet it's like well water's a chemical
well that banana that you're eating is
filled with chemicals
yep 100
i agree
on all fronts and it's funny like you
you've kind of like
given this nice rounded um answer of
like so many things that like basically
you summarize everything wrong in the
wellness space right now um and actually
like i have a whole video on that whole
lizzo controversy and my conclusion was
exactly the same it's like we wouldn't
have given a smaller creator any kind of
flack for doing a cleanse but because
lizzo has been painted as this like bopo
hero this bopo queen that automatically
she's yeah she's held to a completely
different set of standards um but i
think that we all like i believe in body
autonomy i believe that we all have a
right to um do what feels best to our
bodies and if drinking green juice and
putting stupid like pads on your feet
are it feels good to you
power to you go for it you know i but at
the end of the day like i'm against the
spreading of misinformation and that's
why i always say like you want to drink
green juice and celery juice go with i
have nothing against celery juice i have
something against celery juice when it's
accompanied with a side of size yes you
know this is that's the difference
that's exactly it drink drink your
celery juice if you like it if you enjoy
it but don't tell me that celery juice
is going to cure my pcos because it's
not exactly and
i think that and i think that's yeah
that's where that distinction has to lie
i think for a long time i went too far
in the other direction of right don't
talk about this and don't say this and
don't promote this but at the end of the
day like yeah don't promote the
pseudoscience of it but if you want to
drink your celery juice if you want to
do that
do your thing
like you said bodily autonomy that's the
biggest thing
yeah i i totally think we're on the same
page um but i'm so appreciative of your
time here sierra i think you are just a
ray of sunshine in this space and just
such a pleasure to watch and for those
of you who don't already follow sierra
i'm gonna leave lots of links below so
you can get on it um but thank you so
much for joining me today thank you so
much abby it was a pleasure i very much
enjoyed this conversation and uh i love
your channel so thanks for having me and
that's all that i have for this episode
of fed up folks if you liked it be sure
to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on who you'd like to see
me interview next subscribe to this
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen
bye
you